oh man i really got away with one this
time so i was trying to figure out how
to celebrate two million subscribers on
this channel and they say that when the
student is ready the master appears and
the timing couldn't have been better
because i saw an article that said rudy
giuliani had joined cameo cameo if you
don't know is a service where
celebrities of various kinds offer
to record short cell phone videos for
various reasons and you send them to
your friends congratulations or just
asking them a quick question
and rudy giuliani was a member of cameo
for the low low price of 200 you could
get him to say just about anything it's
only gone up since then so i filled out
the form i mentioned my name that i was
celebrating 2 million subscribers i
didn't say the channel name but i was
really worried because if he had found
my channel he would have seen that based
on the videos that our interests are not
exactly aligned and that our judicial
philosophies are shall we say
different and i'm sorry to report that
this is exactly what happened this video
is clickbait rudy giuliani was on to the
ruse he respectfully declined to make a
video for me and we went our separate
ways
[Music]
i'm of course kidding rudy giuliani did
no research whatsoever he happily
recorded a video the same day that i
sent in a request and i am thrilled to
present to you the video of rudy
giuliani congratulating me on 2 million
subscribers hi devon i'm calling to
congratulate you okay so uh rudy this
isn't really a call you're not calling
this isn't a voice chat this isn't
facetime you're recording this video and
sending it to me this isn't a two-way
street but i guess we'll we'll talk more
about that soon but thank you for the
congratulations on a quite an
accomplishment thank you reach 2 million
subscribers on your youtube channel
thank you very much i am so thrilled to
have reached 2 million subscribers i
couldn't have done it without all of the
people that watch legal eagle day in and
day out and it's an honor to run the
world's largest law related youtube
channel one you clearly didn't look up
before you gave me this heartfelt thanks
that's that is a that is a uh
really really quite quite a thing and
something you should be very proud of
thank you very much i am i'm so proud of
it thank you thank you for those kind
words you're an ace attorney and a legal
eagle that's so nice of you to use the
name of the channel that you didn't look
up i do think that i am an a's attorney
and quite a legal eagle it means nothing
coming from uh you in particular because
of uh the fact that you know you're not
actually licensed to practice anymore
because of all the nefarious things you
tried to do to undermine our democracy
but uh i do like to think of myself as
someone that's not so much following in
your footsteps so much as avoiding your
footsteps altogether and i admire really
good attorneys
who are the attorneys that rudy giuliani
looks up to i would very much like to
know the answer to that question i
assume that included in that group is
sidney powell and frankly all of us
should find someone that looks at them
the way that rudy giuliani looks at
sydney powell and speaking of sydney
powell and the whole team of kraken
wranglers i should note that rudy sent
me this video on the exact same day that
i put in my request to cameo and i think
that probably makes sense because
notoriously trump hasn't paid him for
any of the legal or quasi-legal services
that rudy provided and i think he
probably needs the money to fight off
all the lawsuits that dominion and
smartmatic have filed against him and
the entire sydney powell election
fraudster team so i think at this point
it's probably safe to say that i have
made more money from trump than rudy
giuliani has i'll let that one sink in
for a second i would really appreciate
it if you would uh
communicate with me a contact so that i
can i can listen to your show and i'd
love to talk to you at some point
yeah so that's gonna be that's gonna be
really hard because this is a one-way
medium uh it's again not a call of any
kind i have no way of contacting you
whatsoever additionally on youtube you
don't listen to the shows so much as you
watch them on youtube because
it's video you you watch them
in addition to listening to them so i
don't think that i'm going to be
reaching out to you um except through
this particular video but i appreciate
the sentiment thank you
uh
it sounds like they're very very
impressed with you and i certainly am
impressed with the large number of
subscribers you were able to achieve
thank you very much good luck i hope
you double it
whatever the sky's the limit go for it
it sounds like you're that kind of
person i i think i am and probably
through the help of this particular
video that you unwittingly made a cameo
in i hope to increase the number of
subscribers that watch legal eagle the
world's largest law related youtube
channel um that you did not do any
research about before you issued this
this cameo what you mean congratulations
so yeah thank you for that and uh god
bless you
you know
i'd feel bad he's he seems like such a
nice guy i'd feel bad if it weren't for
all of the attempts to destroy america's
democracy i'm sure eichmann was you know
a real nice guy in conversation as well
except for you know all the
unpleasantness in the 40s i almost feel
bad about uh tricking rudy giuliani into
wishing me congratulations on 2 million
subscribers uh god bless you
thanks now as funny as this whole thing
is i'd be remiss if i didn't turn it
into a learning opportunity because i
think there's a lot of things that we
can all learn from rudy's debasement in
this whole affair the first is that your
reputation is everything once that's
gone it's never coming back the other is
that you should choose your clients very
carefully because if they don't pay you
and are notorious for skipping out on
the bill then you might need money by
doing crazy things like going on cameo
for the cash especially when you're not
able to actually practice as a lawyer
because one of the main differences
between rudy and myself is that i'm
actually still licensed to practice in
the state of new york
[Applause]
and perhaps the most important lesson of
all is that if a youtuber asks you to
provide some video footage to them and
pays you 200 to say some nice things
about them
perhaps you should do a modicum of
research to actually you know find out
who that youtuber is so kids don't be
like rudy giuliani or i'll see you in
court